it just goes to show you how resilient
we all are when we have to figure it out
tamar braxton breaks her silence after
being hospitalized
the star took to instagram to thank fans
for their well wishes and support over
the last couple of weeks
explaining that over the past 11 years
there had been quote
promises made to protect and portray my
story
but she says she was betrayed taken
advantage of
overworked and underpaid tamar adds
quote
i wrote a letter over two months ago
asking to be freed from what i believed
was excessive and
unfair i explained in personal detail
the demise i was experiencing
my cry for help went totally ignored the
43 year old said she felt discouraged
and like she was no longer living but
rather existing for the purpose of a
corporation's gain
and ratings quote and that killed me
the performer concluded her lengthy post
talking about mental illness saying that
it's real and that people have to
normalize acknowledging it
and stop associating it with shame and
humiliation
she geotagged the post at peace with
myself
what's the emergency my girlfriend is
not responding
are you with her right now yes according
to multiple reports the braxton family
values star was found
unresponsive by her boyfriend david
adefiso
at the ritz-carlton residences in
downtown los angeles where they were
staying
we're on the way um i'm gonna stay on
the line okay she's been drinking
it's like a half of what she's on
medication for depression i don't know
how much
she sent a letter earlier just ask him
to hurry
the blast reports that tamar has since
been transferred to a hospital facility
in los angeles
to receive more specialized mental
health treatment from
top experts on july 23
david gave an update on tamar's
condition thanking people for their
thoughts and prayers
as she navigates professional and
personal struggles
including her battle with depression
quote
tamar is currently receiving the best
available medical attention to address
those struggles
and strengthen her mental health and her
family and i will remain by her side
throughout her treatment in may the
crazy kind of love singer reflected on
her fighting spirit
i'm one of those women just like all the
women in america that i run into is that
you know we never give up
we do whatever it takes it's like
everything is hard but nothing is too
hard